[Music]
we have an important update on a story
we reported monday police in baldwin
louisiana released a video
showing the moment they say 15-year-old
quan charles
voluntarily left his home with two
unidentified people
kwan was found dead four days later and
the family says it reported he was
missing but the police did not take it
seriously
the police however are saying that this
video shows why an amber alert
was never issued our national
correspondent rica duncan reports
police say video from the day kajuan
charles went missing
shows the teenager sitting outside his
home on the afternoon of october 30th
a silver car passes in front of him and
charles appears to run after the vehicle
several minutes later the same car
returns and pulls into charles's
driveway
according to police three people
including the 15 year old
then exit the vehicle and head into his
backyard
they then return to the car and drive
away the family family's not
questioning the veracity of the video
however
our interest is now solely focused on
what
occurs as soon as that video stops chase
trishell is a lawyer for the family of
kawan
charles he says the video supposedly
showing the 15 year old willingly
leaving his home with two people
does little to explain why police never
issued an amber alert
after charles's parents reported him
missing on october 30.
baldwin assistant police chief samuel
wise told our local affiliate klfy
there was no evidence supporting charles
was abducted
or in any danger to cause an amber alert
and that the video
now proves that they did file a protocol
they did everything by the book
charles's family had previously stated
that kawan had left with this woman
janet irvin and her 17-year-old son
charles's parents say they didn't know
either of them and kawan left without
their consent
which is why they reported him missing
authorities later found the teen's body
in a sugar cane field in iberia parish
on november 3rd
his family suspects foul play but an
independent autopsy reiterated the
coroner's initial findings
that his death was consistent with
drowning however the iberia parish
sheriff's office
is investigating his disappearance as a
possible homicide
for cbs this morning jerica duncan new
york
so many questions still in that case